HUSSAIN AL MUSCATI:
Hi, everyone.
We're very excited
to be here today
and to talk to you
about unlocking
genomic workloads on the cloud.
Part of why we decided
to have this talk
is that the life sciences
industry is actually
undergoing a monumental
shift in the way it works.
And cloud is actually
becoming central
in the way they work
and conduct research.
This talk is specifically
focused around genomics
and how technology is
completely changing
fields like diagnostics and the
development of new treatments
with the use of data.
We'll start by providing an
overview of the landscape today
and where we are.
Then, we're going to
be talking about some
of the challenges with genomics.
And we're going to be
talking about how cloud can
help solve these challenges.
And then we're going to be
going through some tooling
and how to actually use some of
this genomic specific tooling
on GCP.
And finally, we're
going to be showcasing
a demo of how to do that.
So my name is
Hussain Al Muscati.
I work as a customer engineer in
Google Cloud, primarily focused
on public sector
and life sciences.
HATEM NAWAR: And my
name is Hatem Nawar.
I also work as a customer
engineer in Google Cloud,
focused on life sciences.
HUSSAIN AL MUSCATI: We
are both based in London
and are presenting to you
today from our humble homes.
As customer engineers, we work
very closely with our customers
to help enable them
to adopt and use Cloud
and to help them develop
solutions that are Cloud-based.
And our primary focus is
working with public institutions
and research organizations.
So to kick off, there is
an interesting statement
that says there'll be 163
zettabytes of data by 2025.
I'll give you a few seconds for
you to actually absorb that.
So they give you some context.
That is equivalent to watching
a cat video that is about twice
as long as the universe is old.
And to give you another
way of looking at it,
all the data that has been
generated by mankind up
to the 1980s is less
than a zettabyte.
So that means a majority of
this data is actually not new.
So where's all this
data coming from?
Well, I mean, part of it is from
you taking pictures, uploading
them, videos, et cetera.
But a big part of it is actually
from health care and life
sciences.
Medical imaging is
actually number one.
But genomics is not
that far from it.
And the amount of genomics
data is actually exponentially
growing and resulting
in a huge challenge
in terms of how we can handle
it and manage this data.
This growth means
that there needs
to be like a new medium
or way of handling it.
And what is the
end result of this?
Well, we're already seeing a
profound impact on health care.
We've barely
scratched the surface
of what genomic research
can actually yield.
But it's already having
a significant impact.
In 2018, around 1/3 of
new FDA-approved drugs
actually relied on genomics.
And interesting enough,
in 2005, Francis Collins,
the director of the National
Human Genome Research
Institute, predicted
that most drugs by 2020
would be derived or used
using the understanding
of the human genome.
And we're actually
not that far from it.
And another interesting fact is
by this year, the expectation,
in 2020, the expectation
that there'll
be around 26 million people who
have shared their DNA with one
of the four leading
commercial ancestry forms.
So this is actually
becoming a trend.
Another interesting
trend is what we call
the rise of genomic biobanks.
It's quite interesting.
Biobanking is the result of
advances in human genome,
in computing, and
bioinformatics.
And if you think
of it, it's really
a modern way of
storing, managing,
and analyzing massive
amounts of biological data.
Many population-based
biobanks have been
formed in different countries.
And it's actually becoming
essential national strategy.
Some examples include
the UK Biobank,
the FinnGen Project in
Finland, and the Biobank Graz
in Austria.
And biobanking is
actually quite important
because they act as a central
hub for other organizations,
such as farmers, universities,
research institutes.
And they provide a way for these
institutes or organizations
to access data to
conduct research.
They are strategic,
very strategic,
because they help the
industry overall and form
as an accelerator for research.
Yet, they still face
very common challenges.
So let's talk a bit about that.
Because sequencing has become a
lot more prevalent and cheaper,
we're generally getting a
huge increase in genomic data.
And this rapid growth is
really in petabytes of data.
And that means when
you're actually
needing to share that data
among other organizations,
you're talking about an
exobyte level of sharing.
This large growth of data,
together with the complexity
of having to analyze
a lot of this data,
requires a new scale
of compute and storage.
And when we talking
new scale, we're
not talking a few
hundred or thousands VMs.
Like in many cases
that we've seen,
you'd need something
like 100,000 cores
to be able to do one process
from a result of a sequencing
activity.
Most organizations don't
have that scale or resource.
And in many cases,
they need to be
able to do it in
adversity way, such
that they suddenly
receive a large data dump
and they need to process it in
a very short period of time.
What's happening because of this
is that technology is actually
becoming the limiter of research
because many organizations are
not set up to be able to
handle this level of compute.
So how does Cloud actually
help solve this problem?
Well, if you start by looking
at the traditional way
in which things worked and
when you say traditional,
we mean this is how biobanks,
research institutes,
and pharmas all are
set up to work today.
This is the environment
and process that they have
when the volumes
of data are small
and the requirements were
actually quite different.
And how that works is that
all the data is centralized
and in a repository.
And whenever any
researcher or organization
wants to conduct
research on that data,
they basically make
a copy and use it
on their own
workstation or computer
cluster, where effectively
data sharing meant data copy.
So if you think about
it, how is this practical
when you have petabytes of data?
How do you actually manage
to process all that data
if you're talking about
petabytes of data?
This requires
considerable compute.
And many of these
organizations have what
effectively is fixed compute.
And they only hardware.
And they don't have the ability
to scale 200,000 cores to be
able to process that data.
And with many scientists, they
would have to wait in a queue
because a specific
organization would only
have one compute cluster.
And for different sciences
to be able to conduct work,
they have to wait until
the other ones are done.
And another challenge
that this actually poses
is security implementation,
because the way that data
is shared, each time it's shared
in a different way and copied,
that means you need to put
specific custom security
control mechanism
for each activity,
for each sharing of data.
And that actually makes
it quite vulnerable
because you don't have a
comprehensive overarching
security methodology.
So how does public Cloud
actually change this model?
Well, in public Cloud, all
the data and the compute
would be centralized.
And the researchers
and the institutions
would go to that
data and compute.
So there would only be one
copy of the data maintained.
And how we actually
have access to that data
would be controlled
as using things
like IAM, Identity
Access Management, where
each organization or individual
that needs to access that data
is controlled.
The access is controlled
at a very granular level
such that the only
access to the data
they need, and only perform
the actions they need to
for the benefit of the research.
And at the same time,
because it's cloud-based,
it provides an elastic level
of compute and storage,
such that if they
suddenly need to do
high-level processing
with 100,000 cores,
they have access to that.
And it's elastic in
the sense that they
don't need to preserve
that or reserve
that compute power beforehand.
They use it when they need it.
And they only use it
while they need it.
And this also gives a benefit
of having a centralized security
implementation such that the
way to control security here
is to provide access to
individuals or organizations
in a very controlled way.
And you would have a
comprehensive security
method implemented.
So we talked quite a bit about
some of the tooling that's
available and in terms of
like what Cloud can provide
in terms of high level
compute and storage
and the benefits of that.
Next, we're going to be talking
about specific tooling that
is custom made for
genomic data that
can be either deployed or
natively available on GCP.
Onto you, Hatem,
to talk about that.
HATEM NAWAR: Thank you, Hussain.
There are many tools that are
available to bioinformatician's
trying to use GCP for
genomics analysis.
So let's have a look
at some of these tools.
Hail is one of the common tools
that provide powerful data
science tools that can be used
to interrogate large scale
data.
Hail uses Spark in
Hadoop, which means
it can be deployed on
top of Dataproc, which
is our managed Hadoop service.
And Hail actually has
native support for Dataproc.
And we will see
more of this later.
Pipelines on top of
workflow management engines
are also among the common tools
many bioinformaticians use.
We have built the
life sciences API
to make it easy for
these workflow engines
to integrate with
Google Cloud and be
able to run at cloud scale.
Some examples of
the workflow engines
that take advantage of
the life sciences API
are Cromwell, which is
developed by the Road Institute.
Nextflow and Snakemake are
two other workflow engines
that are open source and are
very popular in the community.
These workflow
engines are commonly
used by biobanks and
research organization
to process and analyze thousands
of whole genome sequences
with ease.
But working with common
file formats for genomics
and variant data
can be challenging
when working with machine
learning frameworks, which
was one of the
drivers of developing
the variants transform tool.
The variants transform
tool is an open source tool
developed by Google Cloud
and now has many contributors
from the community.
It can export variants
data to BigQuery.
This makes it easy
to interrogate
the data using SQL statements in
a very fast and efficient way.
It also makes it quite easy
to build data sets that
can be consumed easily
by machine learning
frameworks or our AI platform
to build new machine learning
models.
But sometimes, all
the researchers
want is to simply access
raw compute power.
It could be that
they need a machine
with more than 100 cores
or even terabytes of memory
to run something like a
de novo gene assembly,
or use an HPC
cluster such as slurm
or any number of
the tools that they
can run on top of Google Compute
Engine such as Galaxy or Toil,
which can actually
use the Compute Engine
APIs to provision instances.
Many of the
bioinformaticians may also
be using research and analysis
platform such as Tera, which
was developed by Verily, which
is an Alphabet company, also
by the Broad Institute
to enable researchers
to collaborate on
workspaces, share notebooks,
and easily launch pipelines
through Cromwell Integrations.
This makes such analysis
platforms a one-stop shop
to access data sets and be
able to run your analysis
and share that and
collaborate with others.
And of course, there
are many more tools
from the community and
our partner ecosystems
that can be added to this tool
box for bioinformaticians.
So let us look at Hail
in a more bit of details.
As I mentioned before, Hail
runs on top of Dataproc.
And Dataproc enables you not
just to create Hadoop cluster
in seconds, but also
enables you to easily scale
up and down this cluster.
This flexibility is one of
the key advantages of running
Hail on Google Cloud.
You can easily create
a small cluster
with just a couple
of worker nodes
to configure, debug,
and test your code.
And once you're ready to run
your large [INAUDIBLE] analysis
or large variant
calling analysis,
you can easily
scale up to hundreds
or even thousands of nodes.
And you can also add
preemptable instances,
which can help speed
up execution and keep
the costs down.
Once you're done, you
can scale down or simply
delete the cluster, as it only
takes you a couple of minutes
to provision really a new one.
There is no more waiting in a
queue for the local cluster,
or being limited by
the on prem capacity.
The Dataproc integration is now
part of the core Hail library.
You can create a Hail
cluster from the Cloud
Shell in just a couple of
minutes with just these two
lines you see on the screen.
It is insanely easy.
If you have attempted to
deploy a Hadoop or Spark
cluster before and
configure and install
software in its
workers, you would
know that it can take days.
And you may still not
be able to achieve
the performance
and scale you would
get from running on Cloud.
Many of the existing tools
use common genomics format,
such as fast queue, [? bams, ?]
[? crams, ?] VCFs, et cetera.
But building data sets
out of these file formats
or cross examining with other
data coming from health care
systems, imaging, or even
[INAUDIBLE] or weather data
can be really challenging.
The variants transform
is an open source tool
that uses data flow to export
your variant data to BigQuery
on a standard schema.
The use of data flow
allows you to scale
if you have a large data set,
as this could otherwise be
a very time consuming process.
BigQuery requires
zero management
and allows you to store
and query petabytes
of data in minutes,
sometimes even seconds
without the hassle of
managing any infrastructure
and only paying for the
queries you execute.
There is already lots
of public genomics
data sets that you can
explore today on the query,
such as the 1,000
genome, platinum genomes,
or the public access
portion of the TCGA.
There is also multiple
non-human variant data,
such as the genomics
cannabis, or the rice
3K, which has variants that
were called using the variants.
The other key advantage to
having the data in BigQuery
is how easy it is
to create cohorts
and data sets that can be used
in Tensorflow or other machine
learning frameworks easily.
And you can take advantage
of the AI platform tools
such as [INAUDIBLE] notebooks to
interact with your variant data
using Python or R very easily.
So Color is one of our
customers who did just that.
There is a very
interesting blog post
on our website on how they use
variance transform and BigQuery
to create machine
learning models that
beat standard industry
models in just weeks.
So one of the reasons
many have chosen
Google Cloud for the
genomics workloads
is that we don't just
provide infrastructure.
Our product and
engineering teams
have developed a number
of services and APIs
that cater to the needs of
health care and life sciences
community, such as the
health care API that supports
health records in fire
and [INAUDIBLE] format,
or the imaging API to
interact with DICOM.
The life sciences
API was developed
to enable workflow
engines to take advantage
of Google Cloud in large scale.
This is a reference architecture
for running workflows
at scale and GCP.
Raw data from sequencers
or other sources
typically would be uploaded
to Google Cloud Storage.
And the workflow
engine were drawn
on a Google Compute Engine,
or in your own infrastructure
or machine.
And that would make REST calls
to the life sciences API.
The life sciences API takes
care of the full lifecycle
of each step in the pipeline,
from creating a virtual machine
with exactly the number of
cores and memory specified,
localizing the input files
and copying them from storage,
pulling Docker images,
and running that step,
then delocalizing the output
again to the cloud storage.
And it is able to
do that in scale.
The Broad Institute,
for example,
have used the API to call
variants for all 79,000
whole genome
sequences in the Nomad
data set in just three days.
Several workflow engines or
batch job managers like dsub
take advantage of the
life sciences API.
This includes Cromwell,
as we said before,
which was developed
by the Broad,
Nextflow, which we will
see later in the demo,
and Snakemake, which
is a recent addition.
All these workflow engines
have very active user community
and with many standard and
sample pipelines in [INAUDIBLE]
that you can easily run.
The life sciences API makes
it easy for the developers
of these workflow
engines to build quickly
on top of Google
Cloud and also include
tools that allows you
to debug your pipeline
or generate data that can be
used to analyze your pipeline,
calculate the compute
costs of the pipeline,
or a particular step
in the pipeline.
On the right-hand side, this
is what a typical pipeline
might look like.
It's a previous
series of tasks that
may include scattering
across multiple processes,
or gathering and collating them.
For each step, the API will
create a virtual machine.
Once the step is completed,
the virtual machine is deleted.
This helps keep the
cost of the pipeline
down, as you don't have
to pay for a cluster
and standing all the time.
And you don't have to pay
for any idle instances.
Now let us run a sample pipeline
on Google Cloud using Nextflow.
This is a sample
configuration for a profile
to run with Google
life sciences executor.
You'll notice I have
specified the region I
want my compute instances
to be and the bucket
used for temporary and
intermediate files.
I've also selected which
region the life sciences
API will store the metadata
about the execution
of the pipeline.
And finally, I said they use
private addresses to true
as they already have a NAD
gateway set up in the project.
And I don't want to use public
IP's for added security.
Now, let's switch to
my virtual machine.
So now I'm going to
run a test pipeline
I wrote on my virtual machine.
To install and run
Nextflow, I need
to set some
environmental variables.
I've already done that in my
bashrc to save time every time
I'm using this.
So as you can see,
I've added the key
to my service account,
the version I want to run,
and Google as an execution mode.
So now I'm going to
run the pipeline.
I'm going to paste in
a config file, which
has all my configurations
and project information.
And I'm going to run
my test pipeline, which
just compares the performance
of GPU versus CPU.
I'm going to select the
Google life sciences profile.
And I'm going to add
some options to actually
be able to debug and monitor
the performance of my pipeline.
So as you can see, the
pipeline is now running.
It will automatically
create a virtual machine
on Google Cloud.
To see that on tower, I can
see that now my workflow
is running.
I can check on the resources
and the virtual machine
that it's using.
And I can actually monitor
what is being executed.
Spoiler alert, the GPU
beats the CPU in this one.
I can also check previous
pipelines that I've ran before.
With tower, I can
check the CPU usage.
So I can actually
optimize my pipeline
and select the correct
virtual machine shape.
I can check memory,
execution time, and so on.
It's actually very helpful
when troubleshooting
and actually optimizing
your pipelines for Cloud.
So that was our demo.
I hope you enjoyed
it as much as I did.
Thank you very
much for your time.
Of course, there are
many more tools out there
that are from our
partners and ecosystems.
And if you have any questions,
please share them with us
on the [? Dory. ?]
HUSSAIN AL MUSCATI: Thank you,
everyone, for the opportunity
to present to you today.
It was very exciting for us.
We look forward to seeing your
questions on the [? Dory. ?]
Thank you.